[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone and
welcome to Fandango indie movie guide
where I talk you through the best of
these smaller films out in theaters and
at home this weekend let's start with
the square this film won the Palme d'Or
at the Cannes Film Festival which is the
grand prize it's all about power class
and the pretentiousness of the art world
if you place an object in a museum for
instance if we took your bag and placed
it here would that make it art ah it's
almost as if it's a collection of short
stories about this issues but the main
story centers on the curator of an art
museum
who's just about to open an exhibit
called the square in this exhibit when
you enter in this neon square you have
equal rights with everybody else
it's very idealistic and not very
realistic there is a very stressful
scene involving Terry know Terry who was
the guy who taught the actors how to be
apes and chimps in Planet of the Apes
basically doing that in front of a group
of very rich people who all don't want
to help someone when they get called out
it'll make you laugh it'll make you
squirm it'll make you say what the hell
I really enjoyed the crazy ride of the
square which you can see in limited
theaters from this weekend's how often
would you say that you take women that
you don't know very well and have sex
with them you know their names yeah so
what's my name
[Music]
another really fantastic indie film out
this weekend is flesh and blood
directed by Mark Webber you'd recognize
mark as an actor but he's also a very
established director and here he really
blurs the lines between reality and
non-reality between fiction and
documentary he stars as a guy called
Mark who's trying to readjust to his
life after prisons but in the film it's
his real-life mother playing his movie
mother and his real-life brother playing
his movie brother
I'm bullied a lot really I'm a pacifist
so I didn't fight back I thought for
sure when Jill first called me it was
Jill Jill Stein she's from the Green
Party vice president running for vice
president of the United States of
America it has all sorts of
non-professional actors in there and it
talks about real issues which gives this
film a huge level of authenticity and a
lot of emotion do your best to stick it
out in theaters this weekend and support
these great indie artists it's good to
know that it was a few people have my
best intentions at heart please don't be
stupid however Allah
[Music]
two other quick suggestions for you the
first novitiate which is also out in
cinemas directed by Margaret Betts this
explores issues of faith and feminism
and stars the brilliant Margaret Polly
here she plays a young girl who is
called to be a nun it's set during the
60s when the practices of the Catholic
Church were beginning to change and
there's a brilliant performance by
Melissa Leo as the head nun who is not
quite willing to let go of her very
strict ways of disciplining nuns no
Bichette was a hit at Sundance look out
for it in theaters this weekend a church
gave me my work my community even my
identity and now the church is trying to
invalidate all of that saying none of it
matters so my question is what is it
that really does still matter and last
but not least
Ingrid goes west on Fandango now want to
watch at home this does Aubree Plaza and
Elizabeth Olsen and it's a brilliant
satire on the world of social media and
Instagram how everybody's lives seems so
perfect when they're under filters and
how it can really create that sense of
competitiveness and that feeling of I
want to have what she's got it's Aubrey
Plaza at her most vulnerable on screen
with a great twisted emotional
performance that is also very funny
so check out Ingrid goes West available
on Fandango net worth by far the course
most interesting person I've ever met
by me I love you so my turn amazing
[Music]
fantastic movies for you this week
covering a whole range of topics so in
theaters look out for the square flesh
and blood and novitiate and at home you
can watch Ingrid goes west on Fandango
now I'm Alicia Malone and because I
always love to throw a question of the
week at you buy one for you this week is
what is your favorite film that makes
you squirm and you'll see let me know in
the comments below and I'll see you next
week with more indie goodness
[Music]